let's go to Jeff from Pennsylvania Jeff
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey there uh first time caller uh this
is awesome to be on thanks for picking
me thank you
um
I was wondering with all the talk
um about polling that we always hear um
this might be a dumb question but where
do people get pulled to collect this
info
you look at the methodology of each poll
and it will tell you that and it will
tell you the combination you know
typically it's landlines cell phones
sometimes there are online elements to
the poll but there's not one answer to
that and it's in the methodology
okay because I was thinking you know if
people are getting reached out to on
landlines and phones and I don't know
most people at this point don't pick up
for calls that are uh you know
suspicious or they don't recognize then
I don't know how much stock can you put
into polling in that case yeah your
skepticism isn't new this is an issue
that people have talked about for a
while which is especially if it's only
landlines most polls are not only land
lines at this point in time I think the
bigger and more accurate concern around
polling is only certain people
are even going to entertain a call from
pollsters I mean listen I'm I'm so busy
for example I don't really talk on the
phone I don't even use my I barely use
my phone I have periods of time where
for hours I'm just away from my phone I
rarely pick it up I don't often I don't
even listen to voicemails I'm basically
like conducting business via email for
most of the things that I have going on
so it's true that there are only some
people who are even willing to get on
the phone with a poster the way
pollsters deal with that is they adjust
their sample to account for that but
it's a fair question to say to what
degree can they really accurately and
fairly adjust the sample I think it's
fair polling has by and large still been
pretty accurate in most cases over the
last four years although we certainly
saw some specific instances in which it
was not so all good questions and
important things to ask
all right well that's what I had for
today thanks so much uh very much
appreciate the call
um let's see let's go to Elias from
Texas Elias welcome what's on your mind
today
hey David thanks for calling on me
um How could a 50 50 Senate differ from
a 51 to 49th Senate will Biden be able
to get more done with a simple majority
um I think that he will not get more
done but it will become irrelevant
whether both mansion and Cinema want to
go with what Democrats are trying to do
I've got a couple clips about this
um basically the the gist of it is when
it's 50 50 you need all 50 Democrats in
order to enable Kamala Harris to break
the tie if it's 5149 if Mansion doesn't
want to go with it it doesn't matter
anymore or if Cinema doesn't want to go
with it it doesn't matter anymore you
still get to 50 50 and Kamal is the
tiebreaker obviously if both mansion and
Cinema are resisting that's a different
story but it just gives you breathing
room
yeah
um and I was just curious about what
your efforts are in Georgia if you went
down there
um to go help out with Warnock
um personally I'm helping with tech
spanking tomorrow so
um yeah I am not going to be able to
make it down to Georgia but we are going
to be in these last few days
um pushing hard making sure everybody
knows about early voting we're going to
do some uh you know uniting around phone
and text banking events and uh we're
we're pushing as hard as we can there so
uh appreciate the questions and we let's
hope let's hope that Walker is defeated
there
right thank you David we're looking for
massive dumps of votes for Warnock all
right my friend
thank you very much okay Elias is uh
gone there very good uh all right let's
go to baz from the Netherlands baz
welcome to the program
hello
I had a question because I was somewhat
furious with the politician in my own
country
um a politician of my own party uh let's
say
um and I I got an email for
um in which he explained that um
um currently in our country uh our our
judges have the possibility to prohibit
uh organizations if they're dangerous to
the country
but that law
um excludes
political parties from being outlawed
he said that he would like to see that
changed and
for me that was like it
it it made something loosen me like uh I
got really mad over that
um but because I I think like that's
like the the opposite of the Democracy
even if
like
um even if democratically it's decided
you want to end the Democracy I think
that's the purest form of democracy
um even though it's
weird
um boss I'm sorry I don't know that I'm
totally understanding what what you're
saying I'm I'm I certainly am not
following uh politics in Netherlands as
closely as maybe I would have to to
answer this question did you have a
question for me today
um
no not really them I guess no boss
listen I appreciate the call I just am
not as I'm not well versed enough in
Dutch politics and and I'm not sure and
it sounds like you don't really have a
question so let me look into what you're
mentioning okay
okay thank you thank you all right there
is boss from the Netherlands with a very
very powerful declaration let's go to
Nate from Rhode Island Nate welcome
what's on your mind today
hey David how you doing
doing well so I have a question so with
regards to the calls in the Discord it
may make a suggestion for future calls
please
so there's something called uh stage
channels it's a new feature and
basically it's just what you said it
sounds like you have you the
yeah we're familiar with it Nate thank
you we've looked into it and it it was
not obvious from what we had and the
moderators determined that it really was
going to be an improvement and there it
raised a couple of new issues but we
will look into it again we're familiar
with stages right and then just one
other thing so to add to what you've
been talking with uh Elias earlier about
um with regards to the Senate so in
addition with 51 Senate seats we have
subpoena power boost so we can start our
own investigations and also makes it
easier to Fast Track judges
yes absolutely when it comes to when it
comes to judges in particular now on
subpoena doesn't that depend on having a
majority in particular committees
correct me if I'm wrong
I'm too sure about I just read up on it
yeah because my understanding was and I
could be wrong Nate that the subpoenas
tend to come not from the Senate at
large but rather from specific
committees like the Judiciary and even
with a 50 50 majority they would still
have the majority in the Committees so
that was my understanding but I could be
wrong
yeah I'm not sure I'd have to look into
that thank you for bringing that up I'll
have to uh research that momentarily all
right all right Nate great to hear from
you appreciate it thank you for so much
for taking my call have a oh and then he
is gone uh all right thank you everybody
for calling in we're going to go to a
break we will take more calls next week
and it's going to be a beautiful thing